-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with
Christine Baranski, everybody,
and we're so happy to have you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, the Diane Lockhart saga,
as we --
I mean, again,
she's had two shows.
You know, she went
from "The Good Wife"
to "The Good Fight."
But I heard you were surprised
to find out that the sixth
would be the final season.
-Probably because I had --
I had such a happy day at work.
I was literally in bed between
John Slattery and Gary Cole
in a kind of fantasy sequence,
and I'm thinking,
"Who has my life -- at any age,
much less my age?"
And it was such a happy workday,
and you know, so to be told --
But I don't think
you're ever ready
to hear that something
that you've done for 13 years
with a family of people
with whom you've --
some of them
I had known for 13 years --
my costume designer,
my makeup artist,
some of the cameramen.
I mean, 13 years,
that's your family.
You go from like, you know,
their kids are little,
and then they're
applying for college.
And you live your whole life
with these people.
And so, no, I wasn't -- I still
don't think I've processed it,
'cause I just went
right into "Gilded Age."
I think when -- probably
after the first of the year,
when we would have gone back,
it's going to be like, "Whoa."
Because, you know, people
really get very close,
and it's not the same
as with your "family" family.
You know, the Teamster
is not going to say,
"Well, what about the weekend.
You didn't call."
Or the cameraman is not going to
say, "I can hear
from your tone of voice,
you're upset."
-Yeah.
-And you know, they --
People in
a professional situation,
there's a protocol and a clarity
to it,
and it's a wonderful family.
I will miss everybody.
I will miss my fellow actors,
my crew, my producers.
It was a great show.
It was a great run.
And it was six years
on "The Good Fight."
And it was a show about what was
happening in this Trump era.
I was listening
to your monologue.
You do a great Donald Trump,
by the way.
-Thank you very much.
[ Laughter ]
We're very similar.
I think that helps.
[ Laughter ]
-But, I mean, all that vent --
You get to vent in your job.
-Yes.
-And I used to vent as Diane,
because it --
she was living through the Trump
era as a liberal feminist.
So, I'll also miss
not being Diane,
and taking my anxieties
and anger to work.
I mean, what would you do
if you didn't have this show?
Your poor wife would --
-You just mutter to yourself
on the street, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You take it, you know,
to your kids.
-It's the hardest thing
about having a month off,
is, you know --
-I could tell.
You were so pent-up.
-I was so happy, yeah.
'Cause they don't let me do
"A Closer Look" at home,
because I have three kids,
and two of them are
Trump supporters, yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The 6-year-old and the baby,
yeah.
-And the baby.
-The baby, yeah.
It's just -- It's a tax thing.
For her, it's just about taxes.
-Typical Republican baby.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Whining all the time.
-They are very whiny.
[ Laughs ]
But the other thing --
and I think it's really
important that you stress --
and I certainly felt it here
during the pandemic --
when you're away, like,
the comfort of having a crew
that takes care of you
behind the scenes
is just a wonderful --
-Incredible.
All those years, because we were
shooting the pilot
on election night --
so "The Good Fight" took us
all through the Trump years, and
would that they had been over,
but it seems the post-Trump
years are equally...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And so, it was a place to go.
So, there was Trump
and there's COVID,
and we were still
a functioning group of people.
It was --
Even when it was hard,
we all got through it.
I don't remember people
complaining, and, you know --
So, when they announced the end,
it wasn't like,
"Oh, well, of course. Thank God.
You know, we're tired,
and we just keep repeating
the same stories."
This show
just kept staying fresh.
-It was very --
I mean, you know,
to write an episodic drama
as topical as you guys were,
not a lot of people do it.
-There was always bad news.
It's like your show.
-Right, yeah.
-There's always bad news,
so you always have raw material.
But I will miss it, and I'll --
I will also say,
we had just a revolving door
on great actors
who would come in
and do guest appearances,
'cause we'd have
all the New York actors.
-You had
And this season, John Slattery
showed up in the clip.
Andre Braugher.
I mean, it really is --
-Carrie Preston.
Alan Cumming makes a --
a comeback, and no pun intended.
[ Laughter ]
He Cummings back.
-He Cummings back, yeah.
-You know, I will miss
every aspect of it.
But, you know, I think,
narratively speaking,
it was the time.
You know, you don't want to
keep a show on
when you start repeating.
Like, repeating jokes or
repeating dramatic things.
Diane's anger and
her exasperation
took her to such a point
that she was literally
using hallucinogens or whatever,
and levitating.
I mean, where do you go
after you levitate...
-Yeah, it's hard.
-...to cope with anxiety.
-Yeah, it's very hard
to bounce back from that.
The good news is, now you have
an open slot on your schedule,
you have committed to doing
my Broadway musical,
"Cicada, Cicada."
-Yes.
-And we're very --
-Which needs a lot of work.
-What?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You don't -- You don't
love the script so far?
-It's hard to -- you know,
you talk about character work.
Well, playing an insect,
you know.
And then, it's just --
and a musical of an insect.
You know?
-Yeah.
-But I think it's gonna go out
of town for a very long time.
[ Laughter ]
-That is so sweet of you to say.
Well, we are just so happy
every time you're here,
and congratulations
on an incredible run
with an incredible character.
-Than you.
-Christine Baranski, everybody.